今日は土地はスティーブカープです
カナダの外交部から今日はいい天気ですね言葉の勉強について
僕ちょっと話ししたいんですけれども特にその
podcast どういうふうにいいいいん
ん
uh
入った
英語の勉強特に英語のべきまあその他の言語でもですね
いかに書の有効に誓うカットそれについて話ししたいんですけども
このこっちそのは大事なポッドキャストに興味ありましたら是非登録してください
そしてキャネのところにそのキックそれはまあ中人ももらえるわけですよ
そしてまあリンクにぜひまた常にしてください
リンク合わないしがいつも勉強言葉を勉強しているそのプラットフォームんですよ
あのこの技11世紀にですね
その言葉を勉強する人たち我々はですね以上にその恵まれています
条件が非常に良いです
一つの者の
理由はですねファッカーですねー
その勉強する内容が非常に豊富にあります
あのもちろんその勉強する言葉を便英語を勉強するスペイン語中国語を勉強する1つの
非常に大事なファクターはですね
それはあのいい勉強内容評価材料
興味のあるもの
まぁまぁまぁかかるようなもの
それをやはりたくさんまあ聞いたり読んだりしなくちゃならないけれどもそれを探すの
はあの
難しい場合もあります
昔はもうしょうカ所しかなかったわけですよ
しかし今はそうじゃないんです今はネクスティも使える see you 中も使える
し
いろんな材料は使えるわけですよそのその材料の一つはですね podcast なん
ですよ
今僕はあの
アラブ語勉強してるわけですねアラーム個で穴ぼこはね英語に比べてですね
勉強するそのそういう大量が非常に少ない
英語に比べて本当に少ないそれでも
私が主に使っている勉強の材料はポーてカスなんですよ
たまたまアンジャジーらーというアラブの
あの
ラジオ鵬翔のあるわけですけれども
そこの podcast メインの勉強材料に使っていますでそして
処理をどうやっているのかちょっと今日説明したいんです
だけどもたまたま私の場合はその
あるでしょアラブ語勉強してますけれども皆さん英語英語ならもっと恵まれています
まあスペイン語中国
いろいろたぶん日本語もそういうポってパスもたくさんあると思うんですけれども
私は今日本語を勉強してませんから詳しい事は知りませんまず1つはですね今までの
まあ何でもあっあのポッドキャストがあっても
しゃのう
テキストがないと
だから例えば僕の場合はそのアラブのポットが政治に関するポイントキャストピークと
まぁ10%から15%しかわからないんです
それじゃ
非常にその勉強の効果が低いんですよ
でじゃあそれをじゃあもうテキスト
ソロないからじゃあ今まで僕はその人に頼んでですね
モロッコの方ですね女の方がまあ私のために
所4階てチョチャンスクリプトを作ってばあちゃんのターンスクリプトリンク2
導入して臨機デー処理を勉強したわけです
そうしますとあのもともと10号パイセンしかまあ聞いて15倍センチか分からない
ポッドキャストがもうまあ8割も分かるようにはなりうるわけですよ
そして色でいろんな新しい単語とフレーズを勉強することができます
しかし問題はプランスクープ
11その人に頼んでですね
改定して書いてもらったりすると高いんです
この観光号でも同じことをやったわけですよ人に頼んでグリー食を無償ですけれども
それが高くなる
高くなる
しかし今最近ですねー
は自動的にとらんすぴぷとスルー
サービスができてるそれはハッピー
まあいろんないろいろあるんですよグーがで探せばいいよ出てきますけれども僕その
選ん使ってるのは今
ハーピースクライブというあの短っぴぷしょんサービス
処理えらそれがぜひあの
調べてみてください
で22年前はですねそのハッピースプライ部で
新盆の podcast 自動的にターンスクライブしてもらった時に非常に圧になら
なかったんですよ
性格じゃなかったんですで勉強する立場として
その
いわゆる言葉がね単語が全然
1割2割もあの muchacha 当たらないと言うんじゃねぇ
非常に勉強しにくいしかし今
それは9598パーセント正しいんです
だ
あの最近まで人に頼んで書いてもらったなと
そして自動的にそのプランツ切ってもらったなと比較したときにですねほとんど変わら
ないそれだったら私自信を持って今ハッピースクライブ
使ってます
それでポンて関してもですねー
今あのポイント勝ちのアプリがあるんでしょたくさん
でそれも google すればぽいって返してのアピー
あの調べれば山ほどあるんですよ
もちろん
google 冷遇んボディカースがある
処理と
話題を使っているのはですね ok ってパスつと言います
食にですねもうねすごいたーーーくさんあのう
すべてのあのもで力も政治からもマーケティングからももう調べれば山ほどスキーな
ものがありますよ間にありますの原理ありません
うそれでジャッジ自分があの
面白いともうポイント解説にその登録すればあとはそれのそれの
じゃあ園 p 3をですねあのアピストライブに犬のせればやはり
プライス切ってもらえる一つだけですね
あの
ちょっと僕苦労したのはそのターンスクリプトの親じゃってねあなポッドキャストの
アっぷり
そのアップルの podcast アプリも含めてですね
そこから
あるいはもともとのアジアならならぁぁジェロのそのあのウェブサイトカラー
じゃあその塩 p 3をダウンロードするー
方法はね知らなかったんですよあるけれども部は来週あまり
もう歳をとってるからなかなかうまくできなかったためにですね
その分だけはその6ロックの女の人に今まで
さあ全部 ts 5 a と書いてもらった人にですね
頼んで mp 3-4
色
毎週4つぐらい
北へ送ってですね粘土が者のエンピさんの filo
ハピくらいに乗せてプラムスケートもらってそれを今度りん機に導入して臨機デーその
happy sky 部の挿入酵素も来てそして色でラッシュさんとして
頭って返したら
いろんなその内容ですね政治に関するアラブドンアラブのいわゆる中近東に
のいろんなアプリがあるでしょそれについてまあ聞いたり読んだり
パラと4も勉強してるわけですよそれは皆さん
英語を勉強しているならばいいしスペインゴムチューブをま何語でもいいわけですよ
同じこともできますだから今日はですね
私が最近のそういう podcast を利用する
いろんな新しいそのそれがそのその周りのですね
いわゆる環境がもっと便利になったということを皆皆さんに伝えたかったんですじゃ
そういうことで
どうも
ban
うん
自分の
いっ